brandon woodruff when he's on his game
he is tough he struggled a little bit
though his last timeout gave up six runs
over five innings
india reached bay safely twice last
night he drew a couple of walks
brewers
once again without the services of
william thomas he was lifted early
yesterday
up and in he's hit again
is he okay
19 times he's been hit by pitch and that
was up it seems on the hand joey vano
now with two on and one man out second
and third reds runners lead
woodruff for joey votto the pitch
down low and inside on the corner struck
him out and bottle
is
in
a brief talk with the home plate umpire
that's cb buckner
and vado walking back toward the dugout
shaking his head in the negative
now mustaches swinging a bouncer slowly
hit to first teles
and the toss to brandon woodruff
and the reds are done and he gets out of
it with no further damage they're going
to give the baseball to luis castillo
tonight it's the sixth time that he is
facing the brewers this year the brewers
just can't shake him he's faced him in
every single series omar narvaez
swing and miss a three pitch k of
narvaez
elisao garcia batting with yelich at
first two men are out bottom of the
first inning castillo's 2-2 to garcia
ground ball right back up the middle
behind the back a blind grab by castillo
and he throws devado for the out that
was cool
a nifty play by luis castillo for the
final out of this first inning the
brewers are done we go to the
second inning
so a lead bet on
here's tucker barnhart
and the pitch barn hard a swing of the
mess struck him out
[Applause]
high outside fastball and he went after
it
second strikeout tonight for brandon
woodruff aristides aquino is the batter
playing in left field tonight
brewers leading and chasing the central
championship strike three looking
aquino
watch that one go by off speed and
woodruff
with strikeout number three on the
evening and with two down here is luis
castillo here it is
hey struck him out swinging
and woodruff strikes out the side
has seen his playing time go down some
but he's been hitting well
still gets him swinging and that'll
bring up lorenzo kane
swing and a miss jonathan india
who got drilled his first time up
tonight he's still in the game and
that's good news for cincinnati 2-2
pitch
swing and a miss he struck him out india
down on strikes
fifth strikeout from brandon woodruff
what a way for tyler naquin extended his
hitting streak to
14 games with a bunt single
back in the first inning another 2-2
strike three called
it on the breaking ball they knew it
that's five straight strikeouts for
brandon woodruff
six in the game
brandon woodruff to lead things off for
the brewers and he can swing it a little
bit here's the 3-2 swing and a miss and
castillo comes all the way back with
three consecutive number ones to strike
out woodruff one day
vato called out on strikes back in the
first close call that went woodruff's
way it was his first of
six strikeouts so far payoff
swing and a miss he struck him out
fastball down the middle and joey vado
is out number one here in the fourth
go ahead runs standing in scoring
position now for avi garcia in the heart
of this order
hit one back to the mound his first time
big garcia
they hold yelts close at second and
garcia into the gap left center
that's going to go over the wall yell it
scores easily
garcia into second with a double
back-to-back doubles and it's
one-nothing milwaukee
tucker barnhart will lead things off
woodruff wheels and kneels again he
struck him out swinging barnhart has
been up twice struck out twice
here's aquino strikeout victim his first
time playing in left field for the reds
tonight been a good home stand for the
crew swinging a mass struck him out
blistering fastball that time takes care
of aquino and the pitcher luis castillo
could he strike out the side again
well castillo is up there a strikeout
victim his first time
strikeout would be the tenth for
woodruff here it is struck him out
swinging
and that is the tenth in the game for
woodruff he strikes out the side again
two gone in the fifth inning and now to
bring up brandon woodruff barnhart
through the signs castillo winds the 1-2
pitch swing and a miss struck him out
fastball up and away down on strikes
woodruff five punch outs for castillo
he retires the brewers one two three for
the second time tonight here in the
fifth and then we move to the sixth nick
castillanos is the batter now
one ball two strikes and he lays the bat
on it that's gonna be a base hit garcia
over to cut it off
naked went on his way to third we'll
stop there throw to second the tag he's
out oh what a throw
avi garcia
oh boy that's about as good as it gets i
mean you can't get there any quicker
spinning around and making a good throw
right on the money
oh that was a certain double joey bottle
who's up there now
here he comes swinging and a drive in
the left yellets is there and the inning
is over
brandon woodruff
after a couple of base hits
an outstanding throw from avi garcia
in right to cut down castillanos
and then with the tying run at third
gets joey votto on that line drive to
yelich and left
to end the inning one gone in the sixth
inning and that'll bring up omar narvaez
10 pitch there's the ground ball diving
stop mustaches to his right to his feet
throws got him nice
good play mustache he was playing in at
the cut of the grass
halfway between second and third and
he had to take a couple of quick steps
to his right made a lunging stop on it
and then scrambled to his feet to get
the out and that will bring rowdy
to the point
swing and a miss change up down and away
runners at first and second base for
jace peterson the 2-2 peterson hits it
hard
left center that is down a base hit and
a ground rule double
that actually costs the brewers a run
but one is in
it'll be an rbi double for peterson
garcia scores
and it's two nothing milwaukee in the
seventh bad break for the brewers
and jackie bradley jr will step to the
plate
sim sets at the bell
and he comes back to the plate swing and
a miss and he struck him out
back-to-back strikeouts for lucas sims
of lorenzo kane and jackie bradley jr
max schrock
is on for cincinnati now
fly ball into right field hit well
garcia back at the track he leaps and he
makes the catch
hey abby garcia pulls a home run back
have a night avi
that wasn't sure we got it but it saw
the fans beyond the wall they were all
happy so i figured he caught it and
runners are at first and third now for
avi garcia
the pitch garcia
in the dirt gets by
tucker barnhart
long will score
it's three to nothing brewers avi garcia
is going to get the free ride now
they'll walk him
well the bases are loaded luis urreas is
the batter hoffman
with the bases loaded
deals to urias and a little half swing
roller here comes yelich mustaches has
one play that's first base they get the
out but another run scores
now the eighth man to bat
is lorenzo kane and the 2-2 pitch
swing and a miss struck him out blew him
away with a high fastball
and down on strikes lorenzo kane the
brewers leave the bases loaded but
scored two
right-handed pitcher
against the right-handed hitting
nick castianos
castillanos
takes a shot and he'll get the reds on
the board a deep bomb
just left of center field it's 4-1
23rd home run of the year for nick
castellanos and it was very loud very
high and very long and far two outs
here's mustaches
cousins all set moose stock is the pitch
hey
strike him out swinging
and this one is over